red fire ants like these in the American
South have gotten a bad rap in our world
most people know them as those pesky
critters with a sting that burns like
crazy but fire ants embody some of our
society's most cherished ideals first of
all they are incredibly strong able to
carry 10 times their body weight can you
imagine your average adult male lifting
a one-ton truck huh and let's talk
teamwork you wouldn't think a fire ant
could bring down this giant dragonfly
and it couldn't but a whole bunch of
fire ants can in fact when it's on the
ground the dragonfly looks like it's
drowning and fire ants teamwork also
helps fire ants reproduce these worker
ants act as well ground crew urging this
virgin would be queen skyward so she can
mate sound of 200 feet in the air after
mating the Queen will produce up to 200
eggs an hour three million daughters
over the course of her life
I say daughters because all the worker
ants are females the queen only produces
males in the spring and only for the
purpose of mating what a life huh guys
let's get back to teamwork these strong
motivated well organized insects have an
amazing ability to work together for a
common goal in this case the overnight
consumption of a frog carcass I asked
everyone who works in an office come on
could your company organize and execute
something this complex on the spur of
the moment fire ants if you want a
strong productive role model it's into
teamwork look no further